hello everyone and yes as promised here
is the continuation of the mini Bobby
Fisher Saga we left it off in New York
in 1957 where Bobby Fischer faced uh
maxiva and he was a pretty brutal
experience for Bobby he lost in some 18
moves and if you haven't seen it do
check out that game but now uh Bobby
Fischer gets a chance to exact his
revenge on the former world champion and
the game is played in the Leipzig
Olympiad in 1960 this is round seven and
uh it's uh well quite an impressive game
as uh maxova was known to be a
spectacular theoretician and how Bobby
Fischer outplays him uh specifically in
the uh in the in the field of theory
also in the field of of Chess itself but
just in theory it's absolutely
remarkable so let's check it out the
Bobby Fischer has the white pieces and
he opens with Ponte E4 and we have Pawn
to C6 uh former world champion Max that
goes for the Karo Khan defense with D4
D5 and Fisher goes for e-cap ultrasound
d5c captures The Exchange variation and
now c4 the pawn of attack the Bobby
Fischer also mentioned this game in his
book my 60 memorable games and as he
states there at the time I was convinced
that the pawn of attack or the pawn of
batonic attack was the uh the sharpest
line white could hope for with
um oh white could hold for against the
karokan defense so here are Knight to F6
Knight to C3 and just Knight the C6
Fisher already played this game he
played it against
um uh borislav ifkov in the Buenos Aires
Tournament of 1960 a few months back
where ifkov continued with E6 and after
Knight to F3 bishop t7 and C5 Bobby uh
got a very very nice game but here uh
the deviates from that game by playing
Knight to C6 we have Knight to F3 uh and
not just Bishop to G4 Bobby says that
this is pretty risky but definitely
playable a bit safer with spawn to E6
but also uh there is the the known uh
strong line Bishop to G5 it's an old
bottinic line that fish sure analyzed
very deeply and he decided that it's not
a it's not a great attempt to try and
gain some sort of an advantage against
Diva because this is the line that
fisher gives in his book how black
easily equalizes for example E6 captures
on the five characters and now after
Bishop captures Queen captures uh
surveillette and Knight captures on D5
black has this very nice option of just
going back with Queen to d8 attack the
Knight and once the Knight goes back now
you just trade the queen captures Queen
captures Knight captures and after a
nice Queen side castles it looks scary
but it's really not just a bishop the C5
defends the Knight and if Knight A4
going after the bishop here you will
play Knight back to E6 and this is now
perfectly safe for black no no danger
here so instead after Knight the C6
Fisher continues with knights to F3 so
you can see this is only move six but
Fisher already is deeply involved in
theory and like I said Bishop to G for
some risky business here C counters on
D5 Knight captures and now Queen to B3
so this say this attempt is considered
the most serious for white uh puts
pressure on the D5 Knight also puts
pressure on the B7 pawn and the best way
to counter this is the bishop captures
on F3 where Fisher just recaptures with
the G captures and F3 uh you might
consider also Queen captures and B7 but
it blunders the game away for example
Queen captures you might think but okay
now the Knight is hanging maybe black
plays a rook to see it and only then do
I recapture the problem is there's
Knight
um Dita B4 and now you lose your queen
or you try and uh uh something I mean uh
you have to capture the bishop otherwise
you're just down a piece but if you
capture it Rook to B8 just traps the
queen so that's out of the question but
it is a fine attempt and I know you guys
were wondering about this so that's why
G captures an F3 right away and now just
Pawn to A6 preparing to develop the dark
Square Bishop Queen captures mb7 Knight
captures on D4 we have Bishop to B5
check the only move that allows white to
sort of keep some sort of an initiative
Knight captures on B5 and now not even
even captures right away but Queen to C6
check Fischer shows that he knows his
theory very well and like I said it's a
much different Fisher than the one ever
faced three years prior to this
encounter because this Fisher already
played in the candidates tournament if
you haven't seen that by any chance do
check it out it will be the second link
in the description below first link will
be the entire Bobby Fischer Saga if you
really want to treat yourself I mean uh
Bobby Fischer played four games against
Michael tal in that tournament so if you
still haven't seen that I do recommend
it and here just King the E7 and only
now Queen captures on B5 now this is all
uh was a very well known back then and
it is very well known nowadays of course
even more Knight captures and C3 B
captures on C3 and now many moves are
possible here you could play Queen to D5
you could play Queen to D7 Rook to B8
Pawn to F6 so these are all valid moves
in the position uh Queen to D7 is
whatever played he offered the queen
trade and here Fisher played a move that
was unknown at the time he played Rook
to B1 and this is a
uh there's even a story behind the movie
as Bobby Fischer mentions uh in his book
my 60 memorable game uh he says the
Innovation a month before the game I had
shown this line to Paul benko and he
suggested this innocent looking move
upon looking deeper I found that
horrible as white spawn structure may be
uh black cannot exploited because he'll
be unable to develop his King side
normally it's a little uh it's little
quirks like this that could make life
very difficult uh for a chess machine uh
like uh like Max over here and the move
was also used uh a couple of years years
later not a couple of years actually the
move was used in uh your uh in
grantchester In Living in Belgium in
2017 by none other than vasel evanchook
he used it to defeat Maxim vashir lagrav
but okay uh we're gonna get to that here
we have Rook 38 just continuing
development and now we have Bishop to E3
Queen characters on B5 over trades or
official recaptures and now Rook to D7
and Fisher just is King to E2 and the
point is okay the material is equal
black even has a better Pawn structure
white has a doubled F Pawn you can see
black has two point Islands the white
has four Pawn Islands so uh you know we
should definitely prefer black here the
problem is black has problem developing
the bishop has to still be developed and
The Rook has to be developed and this is
what Fisher will use in the game I've
mentioned from 2017 uh lastly manchuk
versus Maxima Sherlock Maxim played Pawn
to F6 and he lost sorry Maxim played
Pawn to G6 he wanted to rapidly develop
his dark Square bishop and he lost that
game but here we have Pawn to F6 and
basically now completely new territory
as the position was never repeated again
we have rooked the D1 by Fisher and here
you kind of don't want to trade because
this Rook is your only active piece and
here Fisher shows a very principal
decision trade your least active piece
for your opponent's uh most active piece
something you should always keep in mind
when playing a chess game uh he plays it
and you can't really decline this there
is no good way like you could put a rook
on C7 but then just A4 and you can never
really capture on C3 if you capture on
C3 just Rook B7 check King 38 now Rook
captures here and you still can't
develop Rook to A8 will be deadly if you
move the bishop also some checkmating
ideas are possible here also you just
start pushing your past a pawn so this
is completely winning for white uh so
um due to that Rook capture Sandy one
was played King captures by Fisher and
now King to D7 now if Uber can develop
his Bishop then he is back in the game
but of course Fisher will not allow that
rooked B8 uh now just preventing the
vessel from being developed with King to
C6 now comes Bishop characters and A7
Fischer just wins a pawn there was no
way to avoid that pawn to G5 now
preparing Bishop to G7 to trade off the
Rooks and now Pawn to a for Fisher
starts marching his pass Pawn forward
Bishop to G7 and now comes Rook to B6
with check and it's a good idea if Rock
captures Bishop captures uh it's uh well
white is better but you can actually
draw this see for the moment the king
cannot approach that pawn but you can
very easily you know get your king all
the way there so Fisher wants to keep
the tension he plays Rook the B6 Chuck
King the D5 and now Rook the B7 again
preventing The Rook from entering the
game with Bishop to fate Rook the B8 and
Bishop to G7 uh Max of course will be
very happy with the draw here by
repetition but Fisher goes Rook to B5
check and now comes King to C6 uh you
could also try King the C4 here uh seems
like you know a bit more active movie
looking but after King C2 that King is
completely boxed in and it could be very
scary a more like Rook to C5 will be
Checkmate so uh you know and that
doesn't look that great so King to C6
was played and now Rook the B6 with
check King to D5 and now Pawn to A5 I
will be continues pushing his pass Pawn
Ponta F5 uh sorry Ponte F5 and now comes
rooked Bishop to B8 now the bishop is
defended and Fisher who just wants to
play A6 a7a8 Queen and that's it he will
win the game and here Max played Rook
the C8 and Rook the C8 is a mistake that
cost him the game uh you have to play
Rook to d8 it's sort of a weird move you
align The Rook with the white king and
now you are stopping the past a pawn
because if Fisher pushes it now now you
will just move the king king to C5 open
up a discovery and pick up the Rook here
so that's not gonna work but still even
after this Rook 38 move uh Fisher will
play something like a king to C2 and the
game continues uh it's not easy for
black but still you can play Rook to C8
for example Rook to B5 with check Rook
to C5 and if you get if you can get this
for example Ponte A6 King the B6 and
pawn to A7 you can still fight it's very
hard but you you can still fight but I
think um
would rather resign than play a game
like this so he wanted to keep it all he
played Rook to C8 now comes Ponte A6 by
Fisher and Rook captures on C3 and now
Fisher played Rook the B E5 with check
interestingly Rook the D6 is much much
sharper the problem is after Rook to D6
check there's no way to stop the a pawn
if the problem is Fisher saw two uh well
he evaluated it as two equally good
moves but Rook to D6 is much more
forcing the problem is if you go to C4
then just check trades of the Rooks and
that's it so you have to play King C5
but now Rook D7 you attack the bishop
and that's the problem and once the
bishop moves down to play Rook the C7
check and once the king moves now your
trade Rooks captures capture spawn to A7
of course completely winning
uh official played Rook the B5 trick
instead and it seems like it's just as
winning the problem is uh King the C4 uh
no that's not the problem here King the
C4 was played but King the C6 actually
gives decent chances to at
um uh Max over and he uh after the game
he asks Fisher if he thought that King
to C6 was maybe a good idea that he had
a very nice trap planned if King to C6
was played and when he saw uh when he
shot Fisher this Fisher actually fell
for the try but we're going to discuss
this after I show you the game uh so I
don't confuse you guys too much so King
the C4 was played and now comes just
Rook to B7 attacks the bishop with
Bishop to D4 and here Rook the C7 check
King to D3 and now Rook captures on C3
now you can't capture with the bishop
because of A7 so King captures and C3
was played and the material is now equal
but Fisher is completely winning if you
find one move that wins the game so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Bobby while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
this uh very nice tactic and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course Bishop to E5 this is
what Fisher played and he was in this
position on move 36 that Max resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here if you capture the bishop then
the pawn cannot be stopped you've given
up on the dark square and if you don't
it doesn't really matter whatever you
play Fisher will just capture and then
promote his Pawn to Victory uh the uh
the line that I've wanted to show you
instead of King to C4 if uh you know had
ever gone for King to C6 then the
problem is if Fisher continues with
Ponte A7 it doesn't really do all that
much uh because now you can put a rook
behind the pass Pawn the critical idea
is that after Rook to A5 preventing Rook
day A3 you have Bishop to D4 and now if
Ponte A7 now you have this very tricky
Bishop captures an A7 move and if Rook
captures uh okay you can pick up the F3
pawn and you have a Europe two pawns
also the F2 Pawn is saying you have to
play King D2 now Rook to H3 defends the
pawn here and yes Jordana done a piece
but you are up to pawn so a Fisher would
have to work very very hard for his meal
uh so obviously that wouldn't uh go his
way but the real problem is is uh wood
Fisher fall for the Trap If he if he
doesn't push A7 what if he played Bishop
to E5 and this is the move that fisher
said that he would have played if they
had gone into this line uh but then uh
told him just to Rook the C5 and it's a
draw there's no way to do anything here
because you can't push the pawn The Rook
is hanging and if you play well it
doesn't really matter what you play Rook
day four is the best just keeping the
work in the game but now you play Rook
captures on E5 and after real characters
on D4 now you're gonna play Rook to A5
now the pawn is stopped and if you just
push the pawn it doesn't really matter
now Bishop captures an A7 Rook captures
and now it's even black who's better
let's say Rook to D5 check it's four
pawns uh the three of course it will all
you know uh end up in a draw but still
King to see 6 a decent attempt it would
probably uh if had he played this you
know the game will probably continue for
three more hours and Fisher would win
the game in the end uh but yeah even
though he fell for it first after he
showed in the game then after the game
uh you know it it didn't really work uh
and uh Fisher said about Max zuba in the
in the beginning of this game in his
book he said that a former world
champion Dr Max Uber had for decades
been considered one of the world's
leading Authorities on opening Theory
his chess archives ranks with modern
chess openings as an indispensable
source of reference it is no Small
Wonder then when he selects a risky but
playable variation uh Fisher however
just a little better verse in its
intricacies introduces a Nuance on move
15 that Rook the B1 that we've discussed
which Raffles his opponent no end uh
Fisher's method of dispatching his
veteran adversary on homegrants as it
were is deceptively simple after a mere
18 move the opening has become an ending
and the Dual is over the fights on but
the no avail so that's basically the
short story of this game and even though
okay in the previous game that we've
shown the defeated Fisher in 18 moves
but here a Fisher mentions or rather the
official didn't write the book He's sort
of co-authored his own book uh it was
basically after 18 moves that could have
resigned this game because there was
just no coming back from that I think
that's why he he had to mention it
because we were kind of kind of
destroyed him in in 18 most of this is
uh Now official getting back at him so
uh you know after uh three encounters uh
first the game was won by the second
game a draw and third game fisher gets
his revenge three years later but he
does get his revenge uh so there we have
it that's the game at Fisher versus
former world champion Max survey in the
Leipzig Olympiad of 1960. I hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Kim Tori Jensen Orlando's Danielson GM
Thomas rusman Michael Kennedy and
vladislavus thank God for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Chess Championship last game game 14
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and do check out the
1959 candidates tournament and the Bobby
Fischer Saga in the description below if
you still haven't see you soon